welcome to this video playing me homie
coleção 1985 let's check again Nikita
why you're here I've played them before
I'm pretty sure him four out of six not
a bad not a bad score I don't have any
in particular in collection what we
played okay some English Queens Indian
and hybrid and now we are in a queen
cendien we should have 6 135 d5 is not
very common way to play III don't know
i'm not a huge expert let's play normal
moves hope for the best push up over
here not interesting okay what is the
point there if i do this let's check
that's not think so too long c4 i can
take a because of the pin Bishop cheeks
and ce4 again I can take I believe okay
interesting
hmm so let's check here what is
happening in this pollution maybe I
should just prevents you for that move
looks kind of awkward prevent it and
just try to slowly improve I'm not quite
sure how exactly look at this and whoop
do one maybe yeah cook you one I guess
and d5 looks like the pawn that I should
pressure rise first and foremost Quincy
21 we cannot so I can also think about
taking at one moment is still not
threatening see phone okay ultimately
this Bishop is not great down its kind
of vulnerable on that square maybe I
should actually shift my attention to
like we should be three Roxy one
checking the pawn
I'm doing that really not sure I don't
have much experience with hanging pawns
actually even though I've played lots of
d 4 + C 493 kind of openings hanging
pants didn't feature often for some
reason Oh awful did I will look
something Bishop a 6 or what shoot yeah
now the terrible thing is that I'm
immediately worse now and clearly worse
takes takes rook c4 Bishop a 6 and bam
yeah terrible really terrible instead of
some way to justify it Roxy for Bishop
86 rook c8 Bishop d3 room d8 chair not
sure maybe this is actually the
relatively best defense getting a piece
and um yeah that's really annoying
stumbling into such a simple trick ya
know what I lack he is coordination if i
get i would get the bishop to be 3 or
something then it's kind of playable
is the the majority the pawns
hmm that's a surprising move a little
bit
time morning yes I know
a form check
and I a Forester so does win I think
maybe I can check hmm a folk ships to
bishops is reject maybe maybe something
like that is still kind of possible to
hang on with I mean not objectively but
and I get a practical game
j
check check someone that should be lost
let's see how he does it d7 probably not
working anyway I'm beyond the point of
having any choice
no way he just had that sense as I
checked okay white resigns yeah
overlooking c4 is just just a bad word
play it's a fairly normal looking
position but I was stumbling really into
that sea froderick and yeah I said it's
kind of awful I have to just avoid that
trick you know maybe taking let's see if
I ever saw it it's probably around equal
the the problem is if I i mean if i move
the queen yeah he's going be five or
Bishop before those kind of things and
this is getting awkward if I take and
take and now not takes before I mean
something like this it takes and place
be five or what and black it's just
better get those cones are super
dangerous so I went for for that check
and yeah it's difficult to to coordinate
that the computer actually says equal
which I find surprising and here engine
gives me an advantage that's funny the
thing is it's much easier to play with
the Queen in with little time then with
the pieces because you always feel like
you could blunder stuff the computer
wants to go King g2 and not this one
kingi 285 f3 this is Bishop c4 and five
yeah all the computer it's not so much
afraid of this so that's why it's better
I don't know I already felt like I'm
clearly were SIA so check still equal
this is losing check this is supposed to
be equal according to the engine
is this it is a better version of the
game community too okay jack t 7 a-4
should be six check and some kind of
Perpetual yeah maybe I already have huge
problems there with Johnny hmm check
this is still a draw oops and still a
draw brooke f7 draws J surprisingly d7
Queen d2 22 should be six yeah now yeah
threatening who gave aid he has to
perpetual now ha so many chances can
spawn we should be eight it's again a
draw yeah just goes to show I mean I'm
not not trying to be annoying here by
claiming how many chances I miss just
that it's amazing how many opportunities
you often have if you have this this
hard-won spawn this is the bed the
better move on he cannot take because of
books e6 and I'm getting d7 in amazing
there should be eight is again a draw
hey no time and now i blundered that
real quick it's it's a loss now anyway
yeah I really shouldn't overlook the c-4
move that was was a bad idea or a better
oversight thanks for watching